well guys me and Tommy are heading up to
Pennsylvania to go meet up with Leo from
extreme filly fishing we've got a little
bit of a road trip ahead of us that
right tom yeah so we got a bag of
Cheetos a full tank of gas and it's time
to drive
[Music]
all right we've been driving for three
hours and we have another two and a half
hours to go traffic has been bad five
and a half hours traffic is crazy
all right let's let's go a hotel Tommy's
been waiting to go swimming this is the
part he's been most excited about and
it's go time
we're going swimming
well this is not a bad way to end a very
long car ride don't you think
he's relaxing Tommy turned five years
old this week and so I told him we would
do a special trip to celebrate and he
wanted to go to a hotel and go fishing
and so here we are
hey Tommy he likes to later kids ooh a
noise your big boys good night buddy
good night wake up buddy
dr. efficient well you'll get some
breakfast
good morning
come on Tommy up in Adam well it's 6:30
in the morning and we're gonna get up
grab some breakfast then we're going to
a local reservoir about 15 minutes away
to go meet Leo from extreme filly
fishing and shoot a video with him and
it's gonna be a lot of fun but it is
cold it's about 20 degrees outside so we
got a dress Tommy up really warm so
right now we've got him in his pj's and
we're putting his clothes over the top
of his PJs
yeah I think you too awful spot
[Music]
all right time do you remember we're
apart Lin is cold outside it is like 20
degrees Fahrenheit outside so we who are
taking this very seriously but we forgot
all of our hand warmers at home so we're
running to Walmart you'll pick some up
before we meet up with Leo hey look both
ways you got so many toys ok I made a
huge strategic error in my rush to get
hand warmers I walked past the toy aisle
if you ever go to Walmart and you're not
buying toys never walk by the toy aisle
with a kid five bucks for a value pack
and worth every penny what do you think
about your dad not buying you any toys
tell me you have so many toys so many
stuffed animals it is ridiculous Tommy
are you saying you just need one more
stuffed animal Ben that's it no more
yeah right let's go
one on either side and then you know one
on your back so I think you're ready to
go let's go but you get wrestle and
fight strangers oh you are a tough guy
you are feisty what that was fast that
was lightning fast whoa we're here we're
here we found Leo that's right we did
see an Asian guy yeah he's right over
there let's go chat with them it's a
traditional korean fishing rod nope
Internet you want a fish with that all
right buddy
we can't carry you the whole way though
I can carry a little bit did you learn
anything over there
you want me to take it for you yeah yeah
this guy is big on YouTube Tommy's dead
okay ano ha Co baby Luke
Leo and Tom here and we are doing the
young G challenge all right Tom you
getting just going down use your hands
and legs all right buddy all right Leo
give this a go oh man you don't want to
see this look I've been trying though
you got one tom
awesome buddy there you go tom well
that's a big yellow perch Tony was that
fun well you kind of yellow perch good
job buddy I got three okay and Tommy's
got two no no just you're just we're
just documenting that's all so this is
the Gil Angie we're fishing with and
I've got three different sizes I've got
like the heavy the medium and the light
action they run about 46 bucks apiece
and apparently these are modern
interpretations of a traditional Korean
fishing method so they'd make these out
of bamboo or something like that and
yeah we're gonna we're gonna see if we
can't catch something with these Tommy
did you have fun catching fish at the
geonji yeah you caught two perch man you
did real good
there look at look at what you did to
this four thing I tried to catch fish
away okay
oh the hate is real man yeah
what would your grandmother's say your
korean grandmothers say if she saw this
my korean grandma she used to watch yeah
so for those who don't know leo is not
korean he's from Brazil
your family's Chinese right going back
all right close enough right close it up
with your American fishing with the
Ganges on all right you warm hold your
hand yeah buddy I'd love to whatever
half active holding camps for the Asian
you're gonna hold hands with an Asian oh
there we go yes well guys I've actually
stand pretty darn warm considering the
weather they're having those hand
warmers that helps a lot hey Tommy what
is Leo say
that's right all right guys you ready to
go do some carp fishing all right let's
do it we are gonna try to catch some koi
so let's go to it let's do it
Tommy's here too that he's ran over
there to the playset see my gear is
buried just right in there just
somewhere around that area's the last
place I saw oh good times good sharp
hooks are important folks there's a
beautiful beautiful spot by the way oh
this is awesome
we're here at this little pond and we're
trying to catch some beautiful little
koi and it's cold of course so we got to
go to the more the deeper ends the water
levels low air temperature is cold but
the water temperature is high so
definitely gonna look in deeper areas
okay I've got these spring-loaded rod
holders that I've been testing out and I
am going to set them up right here these
spring-loaded rod holders they lock down
like this and when the fish comes they
spring up so that's the theory we'll see
if they work
all right we got the rods rigged up
we've got two of them out set up on the
spring action rod holders now we wait
and see play with you all right Tom all
right okay
you've all got some distance on that one
all right so no luck here and we're not
gonna sit and waste our very limited
time staring at nothing so we are gonna
go try it another spot and see if we
can't catch a big koi or a big carp Neal
says he's got another place little pond
here monster toy that's what we want
Tommy hurry up bud
the first carp I ever caught was a koi
on a fly rod on Brigham Young University
campus I was a student there and I saw
these koi swimming around the pond
wasn't close to this size it was like
the size of size of a living room it was
this tiny little like pond it had a koi
in it I went out there with a fly rod
and a ginger bunny and and caught the
thing we just run around in circles
because they didn't have enough room to
actually make a proper runs I just do
laps that not not so much luck but we
had a great time the weather's not
nearly as cold as it was this morning
and we got a long trip back to Virginia
so I think we're gonna call it a day but
it has been fun all right we just
dropped off Leo and me and Tommy heading
back to Virginia it's gonna be a long
trip all right buddy should we go get
some food
we'll use a potty okay I just left my
camera on the hood of the car and pulled
off onto this road and heard it roll
across the top and it just went flying
into traffic and lost some pieces but it
looks looks like it's still working in
pretty good shape so hats off to you
GoPro for making a decent product and
look at this the rear view mirror and I
see this Kameron selfie stick just
rolling down
[Music]
[Music]
Nathan Nathan Nathan Nathan brothers
don't shake hands brothers got a hug
well hopefully you guys like this video
if you'd like to see more videos from
the outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to